الله
اكبر
اكبر ولله
الحمد
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا اله
الا الله
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله
الا الله
الله
اكبر
اكبر ولله
الحمد
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
عيدكم مبارك
من الله اكسبت اور صيام اور قيام
عبادات امين اللهم امين
محمد
زينوا اعيادكم بالتكبير
عيد تكبيرونس
اور
افطار تدا ان شاء الله والتكبير ان شاء
الله
توذ
ميك تكبير
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله لله
الحمد الله اكبر كبيرا
والحمد لله كثيرا
وسبحان
الله بكره واصيلا
اله الا الله
وحده صدق وعده ونصر عبده واعز جنده عنده
ولزم الاحزاب
وحده لا اله
الا الله
ولا نعبد الا اياه
مخلصين له الدين
ولو كره الكافرون
اللهم صل على سيدنا نا محمد
وعلى ال سيدنا
محمد
وعلى اصحاب سيدنا
وعلى ازواج سيدنا
محمد
وعلى ذريه سيدنا
وعلى انصار سيدنا نا محمد
وسلم تسليما
كثيرا
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله لله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر
আসসালামু আলাইকুম
বদ
first আলহামদুলিল্লাহ
thanஜফ
anyஷ
‏also there
pr the
and st
so that will be set up also so to
have you know make the fam with the can
benit from it they are aware of it and
can wait for till 9:30
have all that set up and beun thatইশ
‏pleas make
you have
make
any notble come
whaton
notble make the pay pleas make pay on
beh or encourage them to do that so that
is mandat there a box back there and
there a box ups for the l also so pleas
‏person
in
7:30
at that point
the way make the pray and start our go
to have the clear by 8:30 so pleas after
you know the next
on
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد الله اكبر كبيرا
والحمد لله كثيرا
وسبحان
الله بكره واصيلا
لا اله الا الله
وحده صدق وعده
ونصر عبده
واعز جنده وهزم م الاحزاب
وحده لا اله الا الله
ولا نعبد الا
اياه
مخلصين له الدين
ولو كره الكافرون
اللهم صل على سيدنا
محمد
على ال سيدنا
وعلى اصحاب سيدنا
محمد
وعلى ازواج سيدنا
وعلى ذريه سيدنا
محمد
وعلى انصار سيدنا
سلم تسليما
كثيرا
السلام عليكم
up make as you canই
so are
few minut people are coming in findas
the another 5
‏Pleas
for
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله
الا الله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الله اكبر كبيرا
والحمد لله كثيرا
وسبحان
الله بكره واصيلا
لا اله
الا الله
وحده صدق وعده
ونصر عبده
واعز جنده وازم م الاحزاب
وحده لا اله
الا الله
ولا نعبد الا
اياه
مخلصين له الدين
ولو كره الكافرون
اللهم صل على سيدنا
محمد
وعلى ال سيدنا
وعلى اصحاب سيدنا
محمد
وعلى ازواج سيدنا
وعلى ذريه سيدنا
محمد
وعلىصار
سيدنا
محمد
سلم تسليما
كثيرا
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد
after the pray ‏So just a reminder one
last time pleas make theat fit pay if
you have not made it or any m of your
family you may think may have missed it.
So pleas that's 15 per person.
‏back up so anybody you think not
pleasay for themইশ and have one more
timeই and after that beading the
prayলাল্লাহ
والله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد الله اكبر كبيرا
والحمد لله كثيرا
وسبحان
الله بكره واصيلا
لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر عبده
واعز جنده وهزم الاحزاب
وحده لا اله الا الله
ولا نعبد الا اياه
مخلصين له الدين
ولو كره الكافرون
اللهم صل على سيدنا
محمد
وعلى ال سيدنا
وعلى اصحاب سيدنا
محمد
وعلى ازواج سيدنا
وعلى ذريه
سيدنا
محمد
وعلى انصار سيدنا
وسلم تسليما
كثيرا
[Arabic recitation]
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على سيدنا محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
ان شاء الله
العيد ان شاء الله تعالى
امام ابو حنيفه من الله
ان شاء الله تعالى ان شاء الله
ركعه
اوكي
اكرا
تكبيرات
اوكي
سوره الفاتحه
ركوع سجود
ركعه
سوره سوره الفاتحه
سوره
تكبيرات
تكبي
محمد
ان شاء الله تعالى
[Arabic recitation]
العيد على مذهب الامام ابي حنيفه النعمان
رحمه الله تعالى و عند الامام ابي حنيفه
رحمه الله
بعد تكبيره الاحرام بعد تكبيره الاحرام ان
شاء الله
ساضيف ثلاث تكبيرات في الاربع تكبيرات
سنرفع ايدينا في الاربع تكبيرات سنرفع
ايدينا ثم بعد ذلك ساقرا سوره الفاتحه مع
سوره اخرى ثم اذهب الى الى الركوع والى
السجود في الركعه الثانيه ان شاء الله
سابدا بقراءه سوره الفاتحه وسوره معها ثم
اكبر ثلاث تكبيرات ارفع فيها اليد
ثم رابعه لا ترفع اليد ثم نذهب الى الركوع
ان شاء الله
ثم نكمل ال السجود بارک الله فیکكم
برادران و خواهران عزیز السلام علیکم و
رحمت الله و برکاته علیکم السلام شیخ صاحب
ادای نماز سعید الفطره توضیح دادن بعد قول
امام ابوحنیفه قسمی ادا میکنیم برا طور
قول امام ابوحنیفه دو رکعت نماز که نیت
کردیم تکبیر اول نیت نماز میباشه با سه
تکبیرات انجام داده میشه در رکعت اول بعدا
سوره الفاتحه تلاوت میشه یک سوره دیگر از
قرآن کریم بعداً میریم به رکوع بعدا میریم
به سجود که تکمیل شد رکعت دوم برعکس اول
سوره فاتحه قرات میشه بعد یک سوره دیگه از
قرآن کریم قرات میشه بعد سه تکبیرات میشه
بعد میریم به رکوع باز به سجود قسم تمام
میکنیم نماز خدا انشال جزاک الله خیر
کمی پیشتر بیا که برادر در صف هستن که اون
[Arabic recitation]
استقيموا الى الصلاه يرحمكم الله
اكبر
الله
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم
[Arabic recitation]
الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى
والذي الذي
اخرج المرعى
فجعله غثاء
احوى
سنقرئك فلا تنسى
الا ما شاء
الله
انه
يعلم الجهر
وما يخفى
ونيسرك لليسرى
فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى
سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنب
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار الكبرى
ثم
لا يموت فيها ولا يحيا
قد افلح من تزكى
وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا
والاخره
خير
وابقى
ان هذا لفي في الصحف الاولى
صحف ابراهيم
وموسى
الله اكبر
[Silence]
سمع الله لمن من حمده
[Arabic recitation]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الض ضالين
[Arabic recitation]
وليال عشر
والشفع والوتر
والليل اذا يسر
الم تر كيف فعل ربك بعاد
ارمذات
العماد
التي لم يخلق مثلها في البلاد
وثمود الذين جابوا الصخر بالواد
وفرعون ذي الاوتاد
الذين طغوا في البلاد
فاكثروا فيها الفساد
فصب عليهم ربك صوت عذاب
ان ربك لبالمرصاد
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله
اكبر ولله لله
الحمد
الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
اله الا الله
والله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد الله اكبر كبيرا
والحمد لله كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره واصيلا
اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده
ونصر عبده واعز جنده وهزم الاحزاب
وعده لا اله الا الله
ولا نعبد الا اياه
مخلصين له الدين
ولو كره الكافرون
اللهم صل على سيدنا
محمد
وعلى ال سيدنا
وعلى اصحاب سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج سيدنا
محمد وعلى ذريه سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار سيدنا
محمد
وسلم تسليم
ما كثيرا
كثيرا
الحمد لله
حمدا يوافي نعمه
ويكافئ مزيده
ويدفع عنا بلاءه ونقمه
لك الحمد يا ربنا
حتى ترضى يا ربنا لا نحصي ثناء
عليك
ش
[Silence]
تف
عيد الفطر
الله
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم عباد الله اتقوا الله
اتقوا الله حق تقاته
واعلموا ان هذا العيد
ليس نهايه الطاعه
بل هو بدايه عهد جديد مع الله تبارك
وتعالى
فمن كان يعبد رمضان
فان رمضان قد انقضى
ومن كان يعبد الله فان الله
لا يموت
الله
[Silence]
سبحانه وتعالى
رمضان
الله سبحانه وتعالى الله
سبحانه وتعالى ايها المسلمون
يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى
ولا تكونوا كالتي نقضت غزلها
من بعد قوه انكاثا فاياكم
ان تنقضوا ما بنيتموه في رمضان
من صلاه
وقيام
وذكر وقراءه قران ونفقات
وصدقات وزكاه
فان من علامات القبول
الاستمرار على الطاعه بعد الموسم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
رمضان
رك
ايها المسلمون
احفظوا صلاتكم
واقيموا الجماعات
واستمروا بالحضور الى المساجد ولا تهجروا
بيوت الله تبارك وتعالى فان المساجد
افضل البقاع في الارض فهي بيوت الرحمن ومن
تعلق قلبه بالمساجد
اظله الله تبارك وتعالى في ظله يوم لا ظل
الا ظله
جماعه
الله
[Silence]
سبحانه وى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ايها المسلمون
داوموا على قراءه القران ولا تجعلوه
موسميا
فان القران حياه القلوب ونور الصدور
وهو شفيع لاصحابه يوم القيامه رمضان
كونستين
قران
[Silence]
ايها المسلمون
ان من تمام شكر نعمه
على رمضان
ان تتبعوه بصيام ست من شوال فقد قال النبي
صلى الله عليه واله وسلم من صام رمضان
ثم اتبعه ستا من شوال كان كصيام الدهر
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ايها المسلمون
يا عباد الله اتقوا الله
اتقوا الله في انفسكم
وفي اخلاقكم
وتخلطوا
باخلاق النبي صلى الله عليه واله وسلم
فالصدق امانه
والوفاء شرف
واياكم والكذب والغل والحقد والغيبه
والنميمه والبهتان والغدر والخيانه فهذه
كلها من امراض القلوب تفسد القلوب وتهدم
المجتمعات
او مسلم فير الله سبحانه وتعالى
محمد صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
ايها المسلمون
ايها الرجال والنساء
يا عباد الله اصلحوا ذات دينكم
وصلوا ارحامكم
وضروا ابائكم وامهاتكم
واحسنوا الى ازواجكم
واولادكم
فان الاسره اساس مجتمع ولا تهدموا بيوتكم
بالطلاق والتفكك
فان الشيطان يفرح بذلك
‏andion
[Silence]
ايها المسلمون
تعيش
امتنا
اياما عصيبه
وفتنا
كثيره
وحروب ونحن
لذلك
ان امتنا
لا يصلح اخرها
الا بما صلح اولها
وذلك
بالرجوع الى الله تبارك وتعالى
او رجوع الى كتاب الله تعالى وسنه رسوله
صلى الله عليه واله وسلم ومنهج السلف
الصالح رضوان الله تعالى عليهم اجمعين
فاجتمعوا على الحق واتحدوا
و وت تركوا الفرقه والنزاعه
[Silence]
سنه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
السلف الصالح
اختلاف
اللهم اصلح احوال المسلمين
واجمع كلمتهم على الحق المبين وارفع عنهم
البلاء والفتن وانصر المستضعفين في كل
مكان او اللهم
[Silence]
تقبل منا الصيام والقيام واجعلنا من
المقبولين
واغفر لنا ولوالدينا واهلينا واحبابنا
وارحم من فارقنا
وبارك لنا في اولادنا واحفادنا
وذرياتنا
واجعل هذا العيد عيد خير وبركه وسلام الله
[Silence]
اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله العظيم لي
ولكم ولوالدي ولسائر المسلمين اجمعين ويا
فوز المستغفرين
[Arabic recitation]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
والله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد
لله حق حمده والصلاه والسلام على من لا
نبي من بعده واعلموا عباد الله ان الله
تعالى امرنا بامر بدا فيه بنفسه
وثنى بملائكه
قدسه وثلث بالمؤمنين من عالمي جنه وانسه
وقال تعالى قولا كريما تعظيما لقدر نبينا
وتفهيما لنا وتعليما
وتفخيما له صلى الله عليه وسلم وتعظيما
ان الله وملائكته
يصلون على النبي يا ايها الذين امنوا صلوا
عليه وسلموا تسليما اللهم صل وسلم وبارك
واكرم وانعم وتحن وتعطف على سيدنا محمد
وعلى ال سيدنا محمد كما صليت على سيدنا
ابراهيم وعلى ال سيدنا ابراهيم في
العالمين انك حميد مجيد مكمله علوم
الاولين والاخرين مولانا ومولى الثقلين
ابي القاسم ابي الزهراء محمد في ايه راجون
شفاعته اكثروا من الصلاه والتسليم عليه
فان صلاتكم نور على الصراط حين تمرون عليه
اللهم يا حنان
يا منان يا ديان
يا مستعان يا قديم الفضل والاحسان يا الله
نسالك اللهم الامان الامان من زوال
الايمان والعفو عما مضى منا وكان من
الذنوب والزلل والخطايا والتقصير والعصيان
اللهم
اعتق رقابنا ورقاب ابائنا وامهاتنا من
النار اللهم اعتق رقابنا ورقاب ابائنا
وامهاتنا
واخواننا واحبائنا من النار اللهم انك عفو
تحب العفو فاعف عنا اللهم انك عفو تحب
العفو فاعف عنا اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو
فاعف عنا عافنا اللهم واعف عنا وعلى طاعتك
اعنا ومن شر خلقك سلمنا والى غير بابك
سيدي لا تكلنا على الدين والايمان
الكاملين جمعا توفنا نلقاك وانت راض عنا
غير غضبان يا كريم يا رحيم يا رحمن يا
اللهم
انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
واعلي كلمتي الحق والدين المبين اللهم
انصر اخواننا المجاهدين في كل مكان انصرهم
نصرا تعز به الاسلام والمسلمين
اللهم انصر اخواننا في فلسطين
على الصهاينه المجرمين اللهم اريهم الحق
حقا ووفقهم اتباعه واريهم الباطل باطلا
ووفقهم اجتنابه اللهم ايدهم بنصرك المبين
اللهم اكتب لنا صلاه في المسجد الاقصى يا
رب العالمين اللهم وحد كلمه امه سيدنا
محمد اللهم انصر امه سيدنا محمد اللهم ثبت
امه سيدنا محمد اللهم يا الله
تقبل منا واقبلنا وعافنا واعف عنا واغفر
لنا وتب علينا وسامحنا واختم يا ربنا
بالصالحات اعمالنا
ان الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي
القربى ويمنى عن الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي
يعظكم لعلكم تذكرون
وكل عام وانتم بخير الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا الله
والله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد الله
اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله
الا الله
والله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله
‏and
first apolog for the distraction ca by
the drone i sorry about that i was not
aware of it so also there a bref at 9:30
so pleas st by and the comp of musl comm
the we have the and
so pleas
9:30
جزاكم الله خيرا
ما شاء الله
[Silence]
عيد مبارك عيد مبارك
يا
السلام عليكم
مبارك كل عام وانت بخير
ما شاء الله ما شاء
[Silence]
تعال
ص
ما شاء الله
يرجع البصول ضربنا ال 40 بحث
[Silence]
ان شاء الله
عيد مبارك
[Arabic recitation]
الله
الله يحفظك ان شاء الله جزاك الله خير
السلام عليكملام
[Arabic recitation]
السلام عليكم
السلام
[Silence]
ان شاء الله
يا شيخ العربدي
[Arabic recitation]
مبارك
السلام عليكم
ما شاء
اللهير
الله تعالى يا ربنا
[Silence]
منك يا رب الله يحفظك ان شاء
كل عام وانت بخير صحه والعافيه
[Arabic recitation]
ايدنا بايدك ان شاء الله يا رب